remember when I was living in Costa Mesa
you used to come over a lot you ever
wonder why the shower there was no soap
dish on the wall dear God I was [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of it you were [ __ ] on
it and it broke off you know the
porcelain part that we put his bar soap
which I've done by the way go ahead
having sex to share with my ex I got
lazy so I tried to rest my ass on the
soap dish how do you do that take a
little seat yeah take a little take a
look
at it but the porcelain went in my ass
oh
my ass up vertically it took forever to
clean up that bathroom which you've used
because the cut was vertical on my ass
anytime I sat down too quick it would
open back up oh my oh God your chick had
to see blood yeah no she's not all of it
yeah it's an X like a Hawaiian Punch
Brewery our combined Force you know
science shattered the thing she was
throwing that thing she had to pull the
[ __ ] porcelain out of my ass she's
your ex yeah you let that one go you
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah my ass is like a
[ __ ] geode speaking of gems